is there such a thing as too much matter
[Music]
Teen Titans go to the movies so I went
and saw this with my daughter today and
now I'm gonna talk about it so a little
bit of history I'm familiar with the
Teen Titans I never have read their
comics I saw a little bit of the of the
older version of the TV show never
really grabbed me seemed fine but I
never really was a fan of it Teen Titans
go I have seen the reason we went my
daughter watches it choose to watch him
more than she does now but she you know
she watches it I saw it that way I
thought this is silly and ridiculous but
it's kind of fun
it's got good energy I kind of like the
humor although I know that fans of the
older versions of the Teen Titans and
fans of the even older version ie the
comics tend to really hate Teen Titans
go which i think is a little bit unfair
but in any case this is the movie
version of Teen Titans go now in case
you haven't all seen any Teen Titans
stuff the Teen Titans are a team of
teenage heroes the heroes who appear in
this film are the same ones from the TV
show meaning Robin cyborg Beast Boy
Starfire and Raven so they are just they
are a team of heroes obviously that you
know they're they they are young heroes
and Teen Titans go is very much a
comedic take on this it's a parody
basically sort of in the you know
classic Mad Magazine style so it's that
as a feature-length film and it's pretty
good actually I think it's quite good
considering how easily something like
this could have really been stretched
out and really been drawn to the point
of death now if you already don't like
Teen Titans go this is absolutely not
gonna turn you around it is dealing in
that same kind of humor and it is
pitched at a younger audience that said
you know my daughter laughed a lot but I
laughed a lot too I think most of the
jokes work really well if you have an
aversion to toilet humor which I do
there aren't
many bodily function jokes but the ones
that they have are kind of extended
although that said as someone who
normally doesn't like those jokes like
cringes at them that didn't make me
cringe that hard so I suppose that means
they're well done
I remember seeing a review that
described this as Deadpool for for
kindergarteners and I think that's kind
of accurate although the way I thought
of it was Lego Batman with less
structure and what I mean by that is one
of the things about Lego Batman is for
all the jokes and all the meta going on
in that it had at its core pretty
straightforward narrative this one while
there is always a goal that these
characters have and all and that never
changes are always after the same things
the divergences they take are much more
sort of sectioned off and sort of sketch
like in that way so it's a lot less
structured than Lego Batman but it feels
sort of cut from the same cloth in terms
of its humor and the pace of it as well
as far as the actual plot goes this is
this is crazy meta this whole thing so
Teen Titans go the TV show part of the
reason it's unpopular with some some
fans of the Teen Titans from various
other versions of them is because they
are silly and ridiculous so the plot of
the film is that the Teen Titans or
Robins specifically who's the leader
really want to have a movie made of them
but they won't get a movie made of them
because everyone thinks they're silly
and ridiculous and so it is it is a
commentary it does meta jokes on
superhero films the oversaturation of
superhero films the excessively deep
cuts being done in superhero films and
this has a plenty of deep cuts of its
own the the dismissal of lightness but
it's it has meta jokes about itself like
this is a level of meta that I don't
think I've seen since South Park bigger
Longer uncut and if it's been a while
since you've seen that remember that was
a movie that came out and a big part of
the plot hinged on the negative parental
reaction to a animated film that was
meant for adults but kids snuck into
anyways in other words the South Park
film was a was a parody of itself and
this is kind of doing a version of the
same game but again aimed at kids and
I'll remind folks my daughter is six so
I think she's right in the sweet spot
she is the target age for this that's it
I do think there is enjoyment elsewhere
there are deep cuts there are a few more
I don't want to say adult jokes like it
there's nothing like ooh that's a dirty
one they won't get not so much that but
there there are a couple of blinking you
missed some jokes there are jokes that
like I said they're deep cuts there was
there was a joke about cameos that you
know I know my daughter didn't get but I
thought was quite funny there's a joke
about Batman's origin that's actually
really dark what was also really funny
the voice cast is great the core main
characters are the same voices from the
TV series so they can do this in their
sleep the primary villain is Slade which
is the Teen Titans TV shows version of
Deathstroke and he's voiced by Will
Arnett which in itself is almost kind of
a meta thing since he also voices Lego
Batman you've got a bunch of other stuff
going on there I think the most notable
one at least that I caught I should have
looked up who the other people voicing
like superheroes in cameras or cameos
work because I'm pretty sure most of the
casting were jokes again a bit like Lego
Batman but I know in this case Nicolas
Cage was voicing Superman which is kind
of funny in and of itself and if you
know anything about the history of
Superman films that did or didn't get
made that again really met a joke so it
moves along really speedily if there's a
lot of songs in it there's quite a bit
of singing and they I actually think
some of the songs might come to sort of
back to back to back and I'm like oh my
god is this gonna be is it gonna be
songs like this rapid-fire all the way
through and there is some more space
between them later on but early on they
do happen really rapid-fire but it eases
off a little bit after that I mean I
really have an
unless the type of humor and unless this
take on the characters just flat out
doesn't appeal to you and I know it
doesn't for some people that's fine but
unless that's the case I really have
nothing to complain about this film it
is a really good version of what it's
trying to be in terms of who it's aimed
at the kind of humor it's trying to do
the pace of which it does it and the
jokes by large land the closing joke
right before the the end credits
I laughed harder at that joke than I
think anything else this year I laughed
harder at that joke than anything in
Deadpool too so I think it's doing
something right and I again
acknowledging that there are a fair
amount of fans who just flat-out hate
this thing and if that is you obviously
skip it but if it's not I see check it
out it's a lot of fun it's a good time I
think kids will have fun with it and
it's it's just yeah it's enjoyable it's
upbeat it's catchy it's ridiculous and
if you know all the references that
they're pulling really kind of clever in
and again the sort of meta level of it
but even if you don't appreciate all the
meta Ness it's still fun and funny and
if you do all the better so yeah I was I
I actually I did think it was gonna be
good because I like the TV show in the
trailer I was like seems like good they
seem to have a handle on this so I
thought it was gonna be good but even
that it was better than I thought it
would be it's no masterpiece but yeah
pretty good time that might it's
definitely one of the best if not the
best kid's film that I've seen so far
this year and because I'm trying to
remember what other ones I've seen this
year and you know they had I haven't had
too many well know I've had one massive
groaner I ended up getting dragged to
show dogs because my daughter really
loves dogs that one hurt but other than
that you know it's been pretty solid for
kids films but I think it's the best one
I've seen so far this year so I'll end
it on that note
Teen Titans go have you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
links to all the stuff to do you know
what it is I do have a patreon but
there's a bunch of other stuff if you
care link
or in the description remember folks you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]